– Mein Bruder hat sich total verändert.
Die letzten Wochen waren ...
großartig mit ihm.
– Apropos großartig:
Ich hab ein paar gute Tipps für dich,
damit du gut auf dein
Bewerbungsgespräch vorbereitet bist.
– Wie meinst du das?
– Ich hab eine Zusage für das Praktikum!
– Wirklich? Wow!
– Ja!
– Davon hast du mir gar nix erzählt. Wann
war denn das Bewerbungsgespräch?
– Heute Vormittag.
Es war gar nicht so schlimm, sondern
eigentlich sogar ziemlich angenehm.
Mit Lisas Hilfe war ich wirklich gut vorbereitet.
Sie hat mir gesagt, um bei
Bewerbungsgesprächen zu überzeugen,
muss man auf ein paar Sachen achten.
– Zum Beispiel?
– Du solltest dich vorher über die
Ausbildung und die Schule informieren.
Das hab ich auch gemacht und deshalb
war ich wohl auch gar nicht so aufgeregt
und habe alle Fragen sofort verstanden!
– Du bist unglaublich!
– Sie haben sofort zugesagt.
Ich muss ihnen nur noch ein paar
Dokumente schicken,
um schnell anfangen zu können.
– Das müssen wir feiern. Hm?
– Ich würde gerne, aber …
ich muss jetzt gehen, damit ich
rechtzeitig zu Hause bin.
– Wieso? Ich dachte, deine Eltern
kontrollieren dich nicht mehr so sehr.
– Ja. Und so soll es jetzt auch bleiben!
Wir sehen uns!
Bis dann!